on la connaît surtout par son passé de
résistante et de déportée à ravensbrück
on la connaît moins par son métier
d'ethnologue en 1935
germaine tillon part en mission en
algérie dans les aurès elle apprend le
berbère parcours cette région à cheval
porte des pantalons et surtout elle
photographie fait germaine tillon
travail et donc avec un rolleiflex tient
l'appareil coup qu'on a devant soi sur
le ventre et elle faisait des photos
paraît puisque c'était sous format
correspond à une démarche à caractère un
peu scientifique alors ce que je trouve
assez extraordinaire dans les photos de
germaine tillon c'est que elle est
capable au travers d'une démarche comme
ça très finalement assez peu artistique
à remettre de l'émotion humaine
[Musique]
sa mission auprès des aurès durera deux
ans un parcours plutôt osée pour une
femme de 28 ans qui n'a pas eu peur de
voyager dans un pays d'hommes à l'époque
c'était très rare c'était une sorte
femme moi je les rencontrais autres
entreprises elles en imposait de prime
abord
elle est extrêmement décidé on sentait
québec est quelqu'un en face de soins
elle observait beaucoup durant toute sa
vie
germaine tillion aura eu un lien
particulier avec l'algérie ethnologue
photographe et le prêt également des
risques politiques comme cette rencontre
secrète en juillet 1957 dans la kasbah
avec youssef sadi dirigeants fln elle
obtiendra de lui une trêve dans les
attentats contre les civils
une exposition à ne pas rater